big surprise the Los Angeles Zoo a few  days ago one of their hippos a mother  named Maura gave birth check out this  photo isn't that adorable that's right  yeah and here's the crazy thing and I'm  not making this up  the zoo officials did not know the hippo  was pregnant they had that's a true  story they had no idea the hippo was  pregnant people don't understand how  that could have happened now of course  they would have known she was expecting  if they had just used this product a  baby hippo will change your life forever  and the sooner you know the sooner you  can plan introducing early notice for  hitters with 99% accuracy and  easy-to-read results and it's so easy to  use simply apply hippo urine  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  because it's good to know urine streaky  yeah  [Applause]  you